الى وجهه جديده ينطلق هذا السائق لنقل
بضاعته يقول الكسندر ان مسافه رحلاته
بالشاحنه اصبحت اقل منذ ان باتي يسلك هذا
الطريق الذي يربط شبه جزيره القرم بمقاطعه
روستوف مرورا باقليم
بعد تاهيل الطريقه اصبحنا نقطع المسافه
خلال ساعات اقل انقلوا مختلف السلع الى
عده مناطق بما فيها القرم دون اي مشكلات
بعد الهجوم الاوكراني الاخير على جسر
القرم الغط سلطات دونيت كالمواليه لروسيا
بعض القيود المفروضه منذ بدايه الحرب بهدف
تسهيل حركه السير عبر ماريو بول وميلي
توبول الى شبه الجزيره
شريان الاستراتيجي بديل اصبحت تعول عليه
روسيا في خضم تداعيات الحرب
لهذا الممر البري البديل افاق واعده
وننتظر تزايد وتيره الحركه عبره نجري
اشغال تجهيز لنقاط العبور مع حدود روستوف
بهدف زياده طاقتها الاستيعابيه
خصصت الحكومه الروسيه 620 مليون دولار
لاعاده تاهيل الطرق في المناطق الاربعه
التي ضمتها العام الماضي ضمن خطه تشمل
كذلك ربطها باراضي القرم عبر ممر يبلغ
طوله
360 كيلومترا دعوه الرئيس الروسي سلطات
المناطق المعنيه الى تقييم امكانيه السماح
لسيارات المواطنين بالعبور الى القرن عبر
هذا الطريق دونها عقبات وتحديات كثيره
امنيه بدرجه الاولى قد تجعل من الصعب
تحقيق هذا الخيار في الوقت الراهب منذ
ازمه الازدحام الذي شهد اوجسر القرن بدايه
فصل الصيف بسبب تشديد اجراءات التفتيش
والمراقبه الامنيه تعالت الاصوات التي
تدعو لتسهيل اجراءات التنقل عبر المسار
الطرقي الجديد
الا ان تحديات كثيره برزت قد تؤجل تحقيق
هذه التطلعات في مقدمتها استمرار الحرب
التي تشمل نيرانها مناطق جنوب
وعدم اكتمال الاشغال في بعض اجزاء الطريق
الذي يعد ايضا شريانا لنقل الدعم العسكري
الروسي الى الجبهات
من الجزيره اقليم دومباس